[Music]
watering your garden is one of the most
basic tasks for a school gardener it can
also be one of the most complicated and
time-consuming tasks as well drip
irrigation is a great watering system
because it is more water efficient and
time efficient than hand watering we
talked to Sean from the governor's
Island teaching garden to learn more
about how to install a drip irrigation
system all right so the drip irrigation
system is it's pretty simple it has
about five different parts to it and
together what they'll do is allow you to
irrigate your garden without having n
water you'll save your time healthier
for your plants
it'll make you the envy of the school
gardening community this kit that we
have here a very simple one and it just
has five parts to it there's a filter
there's a pressure regulator there's an
adapter there's a mainline and then
there's the drip tape the first part of
your drip irrigation system is your
filter the filter either attaches to a
garden hose or it attaches to a spigot
the water coming out of your hose or out
of your spigot probably has a little bit
of sediment in it so what the filter
does is it catches that fit that
sediment has a little filter in there
and it prevents it from going further
down the system if that sediment
continues into the drip irrigation it
could block the emitters the next part
of our drip irrigation kit is a pressure
regulator it attaches to the filter and
what the pressure regulator does is it
ensures that there's not too much
pressure in the rest of the drip
irrigation system the next part of our
system is the adapter it attaches to the
pressure regulator it allows the
pressure regulator in the filter to
attach to the mainline attaching the
adapter to the mainline it's pretty
simple you just unscrew it
press the main line and
[Music]
spirit back on what that does is make
sure it's on they really tell you the
next part of our system is the main line
the main line doesn't have any emitters
on it so the main line doesn't release
any water it brings it to the garden bed
that you want to water in a way you
could think of it as kind of a hose
the main line attaches to the drip tape
and the drip tape has emitters on it
this style of drip tape has emitters
every 12 inches but but you can buy drip
tape with emitters every six inches or
every 18 inches attaching the drip tape
to the mainline is very simple each kit
has a different way of doing it but the
kit we're using today it involves two
steps first you want to punch a hole in
the main line so I have this funny
little tool what I do is I just press it
into the main line make a hole you want
to be careful that you don't press so
hard that you punch a hole through the
other side all right then you take this
funny-looking connector piece
and you insert it into the hole alright
and then you take your drip tape and you
attach it into the funny connector piece
close it up that's on there tight
not going anywhere and what that does is
water will come through the mainline go
through this connector piece into the
drip tape and then the drip tape has
emitters every six or twelve or eighteen
inches and that water then will drip
into your garden at the end of each
piece of drip line you're gonna want to
close off the end so different systems
have different ways of doing that some
systems will have you fold the end down
and put a rubber band over it the system
we're using today has you taken in piece
just fit it into the end there and then
you lock it shut you're also going to
want to close off the end of your
mainline so you take another a different
type of in piece with this kit
press it in you mock it and then this
kid actually has a cap that goes on the
end now your system is totally closed
it's easy to adapt this setup if you
need to have multiple main lines for
example if you have garden beds on
different sides of the spigot
what you do is after the pressure
regulator you can add a splitter piece
the splitter piece screws in to the
pressure regulator
once your splitter is screwed in you can
then add two different mainline pieces
you attach the first and the second
mainline pieces with the adapters in the
kit you can direct your main lines
around your burden and build out your
system from there you can use a tee
piece or an elbow piece to guide your
mainline throughout your garden for
example if you have sharp corners or if
you want to irrigate multiple
consecutive garden beds drip tape can be
installed in rows or drilled in to the
side of your garden bed your drip tape
can be placed in a circle around the
plants in your garden bed
look online or at your nearest garden
supply store to research the best drip
irrigation kit for your garden
[Music]
you